our next guest probably knows more about
Hamas than anyone we've ever ever
interviewed the son of the co-founder of
Hamas now he is seen the barbaric group
up close and personal knows all too well
about the evils of Terror take a look at
this Hamas does not serve the
Palestinian people Hamas serve Iran
those are the masters of Hamas so uh
they lie about nationalism that they are
a national movement and they care for
the Palestinian people look at them they
are using Palestinian people as a human
shield we need to free Gaza from Hamas
this is what Israel is doing he's doing
the Palestinian people the greatest
favor by
uh bringing Hamas down here now with
more author of the bestseller son of
Hamas former informant for Israeli
intelligence mosab Hassan YF sir thank
you for
coming
your your
father was one of the co-founders of
Hamas correct
Hamas has in their Charter the
destruction of Israel what do you know
what would you what do you know about
Hamas that everybody should
know well Hamas is
um not a political party it's a
religious movement that is uh waging a
religious War it's a holy war against
the Jewish people if Hamas was a
political party then we can apply
pressure on them bring them to the
negotiating table where they can
compromise but Hamas as a
religious uh
organization nobody can satisfy their
religious ambition because it's a
condition in their Charter why is this
hatred for the Jewish people and Israel
what what is this rooted
in well now we can ask the question why
all this uh Jewish hatred in the United
States and the rest of the world you
mean anti-Semitism worldwi anti-Semitism
and hatred against the Jewish
people specifically you grew up the son
of one of the founders of Hamas why do
they hate the Jewish people so much uh
there is a religious Dimension to that
there is ideological Dimension there is
political Dimension there is cultural
difference you know we're talking about
Hamas
uh sth Century mentality where Israel is
very Advanced 21st century so the Gap is
very huge Hamas represents chaos this is
where they
Thrive Israel represents order
democracy hence those are the two
opposite extremes that been
clashing well let me ask you this you
just saw a group of people being
interviewed by Sarah Carter they don't
know anything about Hamas they can't say
the words Hamas is a terrorist
organization why why are so many people
so ignorant of what the truth is because
I'm sure if Hamas could find you they
would kill you would they
not well they wouldn't hesitate but I'm
not the only one on Hamas Target list
and this people living in denial
basically they don't know what Palestine
is and what I say you know today as an
American I invite all these people to
educate themselves first and we cannot
lose sight because Hamas started this
war what we need to do we need to remove
Hamas from Power if Hamas stays in power
there will be more Gaza Wars but you got
Hamas you got Hezbollah you got Shia you
got Sunni you got Syria you've got so we
need to make an example for all
islamists around the world and for all
extremist Savages that if they uh
attempt to destroy any democracy not
only Israel any Democratic model that we
will stand United and we will find them
together instead of being divided
like it seems regardless of Sunni or
Shia that Iran is they are we are told
they were actively involved in the
plotting the planting and the killing
that happened on o October the 7th it
would be the equivalent if you base it
on our population versus Israel of
losing 38,000 Americans in a day um we
lost
$2,977
911 and so is this a belief system is
this convert or die is this Isis like
that either the world converts to Islam
or their version of Islam radical Islam
or they get killed they're
infidels well there is the Islamic
ideology that inspires them Hassan Al
teachings Islamic ideology that's one
then there is tribalism you know which
is sth Century mentality where a tribe
used to fight a tribe for 100 years
until they get annihilated or they
annihilate the tribe so this is what
Hamas is saying it's the Arabian
mentality that they view Israel as a
tribe they want to keep trying until
they inhal Israel or get anhil in the in
the process well you you see this
anti-Semitism it's in it's all over
Europe it's all over the world it's in
our colleges it's in the halls of
Congress why do you think that somehow
so many have been indoctrinated into a
belief system that somehow thinks Israel
is the problem when the war was started
by the terrorists the war was brought to
innocent people innocent people were
killed this day since when do we blame
victims uh why are so many people that
that Sarah speaks to so ignorant of who
these people are what their aim is what
their goals are yeah they don't have the
the power to just condemn Hamas as a
terrorist group they don't have the
knowledge are they ignorant and can be
in denial because they just want to
project whatever they want what made you
get away from your family you know this
is a long journey I did not leave Hamas
yesterday it has been uh 25 years since
I decided that this is a dangerous
movement and we have to fight against it
and if they if they knew where you were
on any given day you'd be it doesn't
matter I'm not scared of Hamas I'm not
asking if you're scared but if they knew
you where to find you they would kill
you they would they won't hesitate not
at all they won't hesitate son of a moss
it's a bestselling book and you wrote it
years ago thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else